[Music]
hey derek in orlando what's up my
brother
hey john i'm good how are you
i don't you know what man
it's awesome i'm doing awesome you
i i am excited to be talking to you i am
more excited to be talking to you trust
me so what's up dude how can i help
hey well first i want to say i
appreciate everything the show is doing
for this generation and just in general
i feel like i relate to the show on so
many levels a weakness for sour gummies
i own a strat and a les paul so oh
like it's like the devil and the angel
on both show on either shoulder
i know you can love it or hate it but
but that's where it's at well good for
you brother thank you so much man what's
up dude
hey so
my wife and i want kids and we've been
talking about starting for years now
probably about five years
but navigating that with the nature of
my wife's job coupled with depression
she's struggled with throughout our
marriage
is contributing to a lot of anxiety for
her and preventing us from being able to
move forward in that regard i know her
concerns are valid so how do i best love
and support her as she struggles through
those anxieties
while still kind of validating my own
disappointment with these things kind of
preventing us from being able to move
forward and
you know not necessarily being where i
thought we would be at this point that's
awesome man that's a great question
derek um what's your wife do
what about her job she can have kids
uh it's not so much that she can't have
kids she's a performer and an
entertainer so she does acting singing
dancing
and the big concern is kind of the
physical toll that a pregnancy might
take the bouncing back from
a pregnancy that concerned that maybe
she won't bounce back or maybe there'll
be a complication or
uh you know her physical appearance will
change significantly to the point where
she doesn't get to do that anymore and
it's such a large part of her and she
drives so much passion from it
that that idea
scares her to death
so she doesn't want kids
i i don't she
demonly tells me that that she does
but these anxieties are so strong
that it's
it's uh
you know it it's gripping to her i i
mean i can tell even just in the
conversations that we have when it comes
up that
there's this downward spiral that
happens with this idea that like i may
not i may lose this part of myself yeah
that has been
such a strong
source of her identity and rightly so
she's incredibly talented sure very
capable
um
this one's hard man and i'm gonna i'm
gonna be upfront and honest with you
best i can okay this one's hard
um
man
she's trapped in a fear cycle right now
that is gonna be tough to escape from
and
this isn't just for entertainers this is
also for lawyers and this is not only
it's it's
women carry the burden of this fear
cycle but men do too
um it's being a lawyer it's being a
tv show producer it's being
an executive of any sort a salesperson
um
here's the thing that a lot of parents
don't wrap their head around um people
before they become parents
everything about who you are
before you have kids changes after you
have kids
all of it
priorities
body
thoughts
what brings you joy what used to bring
you joy what doesn't bring all of it
everything changes and it's terrifying
scary
one of the biggest
cha
problems is the word i'll use one of the
biggest problems i see couples make when
they have their first kid is they try to
recreate they try to
re
drag their past into the future
we could just have sex during a lunch
break on a random tuesday you can't do
that when you have a kid sometimes
we could just pack up and leave town on
a weekend and not think you can't do
that when you have a kid
everything changes
um
getting that next promotion sometimes
isn't that cool anymore it's cool
but it's really cool hanging on my kid
or i don't want to hang out with my kid
it's boring and it's not as fun as i
thought all this everything changes
that's what i'm saying
that fear feels
i think if your wife was doing another
job that fear would still be there it's
what i'm saying
okay i think this is more about kids
than it is about being an actress and i
could be way off and i'm not talking to
her i'm talking to you
um
i know too many actresses too many
people in in the profession that
have multiple children and you make it
work and
yes you age and yes your body changes
and sometimes it changes
everybody changes everything the id how
about this the idea that
uh how old is she now
uh she's 30 now okay
she's gonna be different at 33.
she's way different 35 she'll be
different at 40.
differences in her body and her
abilities and her
appearance those things are all gonna
happen to all of us whether we have kids
or not
now i don't want to undermine actresses
and actors especially actresses have a
different type of pressure it's real i
get that
but in the same
let's take acting off the table let's
take my job for instance i i have a lot
of opportunities to go speak all over
the country at corporate events private
events all kind of stuff
in one breath i can say i really want to
spend more time with my kids i really do
and when
justin who handles all of the the
speaking contracts calls and says hey i
got another one for you for this much
money and i go yeah i'm in
what i have said what i've demonstrated
is that i want money more than i want to
spend time with my kids right now
not i'm not going to judge that that's a
fact that's what i just did
or i could say
i want to spend more time right now with
my kids right now so i'm going to turn
the speaking gig down
it's an either or proposition
and
the only way i have seen through that
i've been able to navigate that is
through the like what my friend christy
wright called this it's the seasons
it's to say this season
i want to pay this stuff off and this
season i don't want to have a mortgage
and this season i'm going to pile up
cash and so the cost of that
is going to be time with my family and
we're all on the same page we're all
talking about it then as you mentioned
earlier this picture you had that looks
different we're all on the same page
about that looks like
right now your wife can say she wants
kids and that's cool
but she doesn't she wants to be an
actress
and she wants to keep the picture of
being an actress alive as long as
possible because she's scared about
what's going to do to her
and there's i'm telling you right now
there's deeper fears than that that i
think you'll need to go talk to a
marriage counselor and talk through
i think there's deeper things here than
that
um
there's just too many people in the
profession that have kids that
things are great you know what i mean
yeah no i 100 agree i
so so we both have have been talking to
therapists individually and then reading
through
like for example we started reading the
uh adult children of emotional images
yeah good for you dude like
yeah this like for one chapter in like
she's teary-eyed yeah i mean
this is this is her and i think you're
absolutely right in the sense that
there's i mean there are people who are
peers with her in the roles and the
capacities that she's doing who do have
kids yeah it's it's possible absolutely
what what do i do
i mean what what can i do in in those
scenarios in those conversations i mean
i can't imagine that saying back to her
is like yeah you're right it will be
completely different it will
like you probably will
lose this or
like i can't imagine that's going to be
helpful but do i need to bring that kind
of dose of reality to it it's it's
when you phrase it like loss you will
lose this
um
that's a scarcity mindset it's not
looking at every single thing you're
going to gain
and it's looking at there is a finite
amount of this and if i don't have that
everything is over
and that's you can't do that kind of
math with kids
you can't do that kind of math with
family expansion you can do that kind of
math with healing
um in the in the previous call when i
was just talking to that young woman
about
she's got so much rage in her because
what her dad did to her mom
that she can't at this moment let that
go enough to not lose her current fiance
because she's so full of rage
so full of rage and anger
there is it comes these moments are
these either or propositions and what
she doesn't understand is
if she let go of that rage
and turned to and accepted love and
worked hard on love she has no idea what
how good that would feel right now it's
all about safety and protection and your
wife's in a similar situation
she's got the whole idea of being an
actress and an entertainer it's all
scarcity mindset there's one role and
500 people trying to get that role
that's just the nature of that business
i'm in that business it's it's tough
it's hard to
live into
um
non-scarcity mindsets right that
everybody wins on these deals
and this idea that man i don't care who
you are when you're 30 your skin looks
different than when you're 20 your body
looks different when you're 40
dude homie it all goes sideways right
it just it just happens and that's why i
don't think this has to do with this
so
what i've what i've seen in these kind
of situations and i've i've mostly seen
this in academic situations i have a
friend of mine she's an incredible
scholar her husband's an incredible
scholar they have lost out on jobs
because she is quote unquote a breeder
she is somebody who had kids and wasn't
totally dedicated to her
um academic
slice
they called her a breeder for crying out
loud okay
yeah um
what
i've seen this over and over and
ultimately
what people try to do is they start
trying to solve the kid question do we
have a kid not have a kid we have a kid
and another kid that's not the issue the
issue is i've got to be at peace with
who i am where i'm headed where i'm
going with my spouse what do we want
this thing to look like five years three
years six years down the road and we're
gonna take this in seasons what's this
season going to look like
let's be on the same page about let's do
six months of going all in
or let's do
12 months of going all in
and then let's reevaluate and see where
your career is at where my heart is with
having kids where your heart's having
kids and let's be honest about that
season but it it's you have to do
brother you got to let your picture go
you gotta let that sucker go
it's not gonna be what it was you
thought you'd have two kids by now and
you're 30. you don't okay
you're gonna have to grieve that picture
it's not it's not happening it's not
reality cool let's get intentional about
making a new one
and let's get really intentional about
healing because your wife is scared
about other things and it's coming out
with working kids
and anybody listening to this wrestling
about this conversation you gotta step
away from the kid thing because it
becomes the proxy war it's not the real
challenge here does she have a tough
tough road growing up
yeah yeah absolutely and that's why i
think a lot of this
the validation that she receives from
work there you go is
exactly where like adapts with the loss
yeah i think that is that's where the
loss is it's not the field it's not the
profession it's the validation the
success yeah yeah the success and the
validation that she's had there um
because she didn't get a lot of that
growing up um
so i think it's good to affirm that's
real it's real that that validation's
real
um
it feels real it's not it's fleeting and
it will go away soon all right they'll
find the next the next darling and it'll
be on to the next
um
if i'm you and this is my wife and we're
working through this together
i want to back all the way out of the
kid conversation and ask where are we
headed how can we heal from these
childhood wounds how can we make some
decisions about what kids are gonna look
like and then we gotta put some stuff on
the calendar
and we gotta be highly intentional about
it
there will come a moment probably be
best to have a counselor in the room
when somebody calls her on
the math that she's trying to do that's
not working i really really want kids
and i really really want this well you
gotta it's gonna cost you one or the
other
and by the way it's not you can be both
but there will be a season right there
will be seasons of shifting and change
um somebody's gonna have to call her on
that
waiting until y'all are in a fight or
into an our hard disagreement or
everybody's crying or have tears that's
not the season to do that that's not the
moment to do that does that make sense
yeah that does
um
ultimately
go ahead go ahead
oh i was just gonna ask can i ask you
one more question about like this idea
of grieving the idea that you know i had
a picture in my head it's not there yeah
and like processing through that would
you
would you say to go all the way through
this idea of like grieving the idea
because i've had my you know or what
moment you know of like let's say this
doesn't happen that these these take
years and years to get through and
ultimately at the end of the day the
decision is like you know what
it's just not gonna happen
yeah um and i've i've had that or what
conversation in my head like would you
leave her and go marry somebody else so
you can have kids
exactly right and and like i'm just
i've made
the vows that i made to her were not
conditional upon that you know and
that's that's where i stand with it but
um
do i go through the entire process of
like grieving the entire idea right now
and if it does work out great
now you're not grieving that you're
never gonna have kids you're grieving
that i had this expectation right here
and it it's not
and what you're trying to do is to get
your body to stop reacting as though
then something's on fire
it's not it's already burned down
yeah you know what i mean
so there's something about when somebody
calls you and says hey your house is on
fire there is a part of your body that
goes into defcon i gotta get there and
get the stuff out
your body responds differently when
someone calls you says hey i'm sorry
there's a hurricane you lost everything
everything's ash
that's a sorrow that's not a response
that is the depths of grief not fight or
flight
right now your body's in fight or flight
because you're still trying to make this
thing happen and it's not
it's past you're 20 you're 30 years old
you thought you'd have two kids but now
you don't
and so there's something about
acknowledging the present the reality of
it and it's gonna hurt man it's a
reality sucks it's i mean just sitting
there being like
and then there's a period in that
sentence and then the real question is
we're not going back i'm already 30. i
still don't have two kids
i don't have four kids running around
here the real question is i'm holding a
pin
what am i gonna write next and what are
we gonna write next and the good thing
for you derek cause you've already gone
through the or what will i leave her the
answer is no
and so now it's about can we make this
work
i want to know are we going to have
children
and it is not about being an actress
that is that's the proxy it's not
there's something going on deeper than
here deeper than that and it probably
has to do with her interaction with her
parents whether that was trauma abuse
neglect all those things combined
healing there will be really important
and then having an honest truthful
conversation about
man everything changes in the
entertainment industry especially when
you are actress when you're dancer when
you're um you do movement that's a young
kid's game man and or you transition to
different roles that look different that
move on different all this have changes
and it's just being honest about seasons
what seasons we're in what what changes
are coming
whether we have kids or not and then
what is a kid actually going to do to
that situation
i just know too many actresses that are
awesome awesome awesome i got kids too
many people in front of cameras that do
great stuff they're incredible
but it's easy to get trapped in that
scarcity mindset especially when you're
working from a place of trauma derek
your wife is lucky to have you in your
life that you love her
um i'm going to suggest not talking
about kids for a season let's get back
to healing because that kid's adding a
lot of pressure let's get back to
healing this childhood stuff healing
this relationship you grieve your stuff
and let's paint a picture about where
we're headed and let's be really clear
about putting stuff on the calendar if
we don't have this by 31 then we're
going to try this and we're going to try
that here's our combined goals here and
let's move forward there
thank you so much for calling me i'm
proud of you for doing work with
counseling too man that is incredible
awesome awesome awesome